tout le monde se souvient bien sûr du
nuage de tchernobyl qui se sent est
arrêté à la frontière française
vingt ans après l'explosion du réacteur
le professeur pierre pellerin qui
dirigeait alors le service central de
protection contre les rayonnements
ionisants devrait être mise en examen
aujourd'hui pour tromperie aggravée
c'est lui qui avait à l'époque initié la
communication officielle du gouvernement
français en occultant les risques de
radioactivité
notamment dans l'est et le sud du pays
josé blandin pierre christian lowe 10
mai 86 le professeur pellerin chef de
file de l'autorité nucléaire révèle que
la france a bien été touchée par le
nuage radioactif des doses 100 fois
supérieur à la normale mais l'annoncé
tardive car quinze jours se sont écoulés
après l'accident de la centrale
ukrainienne
quinze jours pendant lesquels on a tenu
ce discours destiné à rassurer
de fait aucune raison de parler
conditions métérologiques elle même que
quoi que ce soit soit mesurée en france
la toxicité l'on peut être catégorique
ça ne présente absolument aucun danger
c'est vos discours vont déboucher sur un
reproche celui d'avoir minimisé le
danger radioactif
avec peut-être la complicité des
politiques le problème c'est que ce
n'est pas leur métier de faire de la
communication médiatique malgré que nous
allions nous était surchargé de travail
nous avons quand même fait toute
information
toute l'information qu'ils ont pu ou
qu'ils ont voulu c'est là toute la
question
quoi qu'il en soit à l'époque la france
ne juge pas utile d'interdire la
consommation de produits frais ce qui
conduira des malades de la thyroïde a
porté plainte pour mise en danger
d'autrui
il rappelle qu'en allemagne le lait a
été interdite on a les preuves que ce
qui était invendable en europe est
passée en france était liquide en france
au niveau marchandises alimentaires
qu'on veut savoir c'est de la
responsabilité politique pourquoi les
politiques comment il était il informé
pourquoi partie moment où ils ont été
informés ils n'ont rien dit qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent protéger
c'est pour tenter de répondre à toutes
ces questions que le professeur pellerin
devrait être mis en examen pour
tromperie aggravée sur les retombées de
tchernobyl